der mann der das angerichtet hat wurde
einmal als lupenreiner demokrat
bezeichnet und zwar von altkanzler
gerhard schröder und auch bei ihm gibt
es heute neue entwicklungen der trainer
hat sein gesamtes büro verloren diese
nachricht hat uns gerade alt alle
mitarbeiter haben gekündigt wegen seiner
weigerung russische mandate abzugeben
und sich klar von vladimir putin zu
distanzieren dass die nachrichten der
kollegen von the pioneer gerade also es
wird einsam um gerd schröder tagelange
wochenlange monatelange diskussion um
sein büro um das steuergeld dass er
immer noch von uns empfängt bei uns im
studio bild live chef claus strunz und
jetzt sagt nicht die spd wir schmeißen
ihn raus sagt nicht der deutsche staat
du kriegst sein büro nicht mehr aber
sagen die menschen wir wollen mit dir
gerd schröder nicht mehr arbeiten nichts
mehr zu tun haben und das genau sagt
alles nämlich dass die mitarbeiter jetzt
nachholen was der staat und die partei
bisher versäumt haben das ist grandios
von den mitarbeitern das ist
zivilcourage das ist bürger sind das ist
wir machen nicht alles mit das ist
haltung das ist das beste was man im
grunde von mitarbeitern von bürgern von
mitmenschen sich vorstellen kann ganz
ganz ganz ganz große hochachtung weil
das fällt ja nach einer so langen
zusammenarbeit an einer so
herausgehobenen position auch nicht
leicht das sind zur speise und daran
kann man sehen wie nah es den
mitarbeitern gehen muss und wie nah es
uns allen gehen muss dass gerhard
schröder der unser bundeskanzler war ich
sage es freimütig raus den ich mal
gewählt habe der für mich eine eine
veränderung in deutschland gebracht hat
die neue mitte der eine neue generation
von politik sozusagen mit im schlepptau
hatte dieser mann der von von vielen
menschen gewählt wurde in deutschland
vernichtet grad sein lebenswerk und
schweigt und schweigt und schweigt wir
wollen ja auch seit tagen mit ihm
sprechen dass es sich erklären kann dann
hat er irgendwie da
bei linkedin auf einer plattform
irgendwas gepostet völlig kalt
technokratisch fast in einer art putin
sk rhetorik jetzt ist der moment
gekommen wo wenn schon der staat der in
alimentiert als ex-kanzler nicht handelt
die partei handeln muss dieser mann ist
für die stolze spd zur schande geworden
und sie muss jetzt einen
parteiausschluss verfahren anstrengen
und ich glaube dass man das mit der lage
der dinge auch durchsetzen kann partei
ausschlussverfahren scheine sich
parteien oft weil es kompliziert ist und
dann haben sie sorge wenn es dann am
ende nicht durchgeht vor gericht egal
man muss jetzt erhaltung zeigen klare
kante zeigen dieser mann hat in dieser
spd nichts mehr verloren denn er
paktiert offen mit einem
kriegsverbrecher wenn das kein grund für
ein parteiausschluss ist dann weiß ja
nie mehr und die die entwicklung zeigt
ja auch dass kein durchkommen mehr
offenbar zu ihm ist denn die mitarbeiter
werden mit sicherheit auch vorher
mehrfach das gespräch gesucht haben wie
erklärst du dir das dass er da nicht
abweicht dass er sich nicht äußert dass
er offenbar muss man sagen aber auch
durch ein sieht also ich glaube ich kann
es mir wahrscheinlich gar nicht erklären
weil schüler in seiner ganzen politik
als politisches tier muss ihr erkannt
haben dass sich der wind gedreht hat um
es mal ein bisschen einfach zu sagen und
das ist jetzt nicht mehr geht an der
seite von wladimir putin als dessen
agent als dessen lobbyist zu stehen dass
man jetzt an der seite der bundesbürger
und der menschen die für die freiheit
kämpfen ich füge hinzu die in der
ukraine für die freiheit stand stehen
muss und nicht bei denen das jung bringt
das muss ja sogar gerhard schröder
erkennen und das sogar bezieht sich auf
folgende ich glaube es gibt bei gerhard
schröder in der persönlichkeitsstruktur
etwas was mir eigentlich sympathisch ist
das ist wenn ich mein wort gegeben habe
dann halte ich das auch komme was wolle
also man es wahrscheinlich früher als
eine
männerbund eine männerbund philosophie
eine männerbund idee betrachtet dem
dadurch grundsätzlich hochachtung davor
und ich finde dass man auch nicht bei
jedem furz der gegen den freund gesagt
wird und bei jedem depot fax den man
einem
kollegen oder einem verbündeten vorhält
gleich die reißleine ziehen muss wir
sind hier aber seit tagen in einem
terror wo all das nicht mehr gelten darf
jetzt ist die kraft der vernunft und die
das eintreten für die freiheit stärker
als jeder handschlag den mann gegeben
hat und die millionen die er da offenbar
von gazprom bekommt also von wladimir
putin um es mal deutlich zu sagen ist
schmutziges geld es kann ja wohl nicht
sein dass sich schalke 04 vom trikot
sponsor gazprom trend unser ehemaliger
kanzler trennt sich dort aber nicht von
seinen ämtern das finde ich wirklich an
diesem morgen
unglaublich beschämend